each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon buenas tardes es un
placer para me estar aquí en colombia
encarta janice la Primera's kb estado y
la fiebre see Ossa me encanta mucho el
pais voy a dar la presentazione ingles
por que cuando suba madondo me DI cuenta
Callie monton de palabras que no sabia
como decir la en en espanol pero SI lo
algunas preguntas que las buenas n engl
soe n1 español se to del make represent
a representation in English feel free to
as many questions value half as you go
then I'm going to be talking about some
of the research that has been going into
Microsoft Connect you've heard some
things about connect in this faculty
summit in brick rush it's keynote in
another talks so today I'm going to be
describing a little under the hood how
some of the technology that we develop
works so first of all how did the
project started there was a person in
the Xbox organization called Alex kidman
who was asking himself the question how
about if we could build our video game
without using a controller you don't
hold anything how would that change
things and the key thing is that down
there premise is that down might enable
a whole new generation of people to use
game video game consoles today most of
the video game players are like hardcore
players are like shooting them and you
know just explosions that perhaps your
interest in the new generation of
players how would you do it if you have
nothing just use yourself you are the
controller and in fact that was the that
was the slogan of the of the system so
let me show you first a video for those
of you that haven't seen what our
connect can do in the case in the
context of a video game
Connect turn out to be the fastest
selling consumer electronic device in
history according to the Guinness World
Records is sold like 8 million copies in
60 days but the thing that interested me
the most besides the fact that it was
nice to see commercial success is when I
was looking at the reviews and I saw
what some of the reporters were writing
there was one reporter that really
caught my attention he was saying rather
than me telling you what I think about
the device I want to tell you what my
ten-year-old said about it I was doing
this making some gestures my
ten-year-old was looking at me quiet
normally it's not quiet jumping around
or do it's just quite looking at me and
after a while he said bad can I also
play with the force like like a big star
Wars fan and that we had struck me
because that means that this device was
magical to a kid a ten-year-old that
sees all the science fiction movies
that's actually fairly natural and that
what this is trying to do something that
is natural that you get immersed in and
you feel like you're part of the game
you don't need to learn anything just go
and do it and it turns out that most of
the young generation are the people that
can handle keen it much faster than the
older people so it's very natural and
maybe we're just used to the mechanics
of keyboards and mice and touch screens
and the kids are the ones that you know
they just are natural for this so now
that we know what this can do let's go a
little bit more in detail of what it has
inside from the hardware point of view
and then I'll tell you from the software
point of view and all the possibilities
besides gaming so this is the sensor and
you can see from inside that it has an
infrared projector we will see what that
is for an infrared camera also called a
def camera a regular camera welcome RGB
camera we have four microphones modder
so that it can move and to adjust for
the field of view in a USB cable and it
sold for 150 dollars so that was like a
big revolution because some of the def
cameras that
we describing later some of that
technology has existed for a while but
you have to pay like twenty to thirty
thousand dollars and you have no
software on top of it so as a result
this is like a revolution changed
dramatically the equation so it connects
solid shipping in the United States and
a few other countries in November with a
few games and the interesting thing is
that initially was released just for
gaming but within a very little period
of time very short period of time there
were a bunch of this skin that hacks
there is a website you can really see
that there is Kim net hacks com that you
can go and see and it turns out that as
of yesterday that I looked there were 58
pages and there's like back in December
even there was already 90 projects so
there's like hundreds and hundreds of
key net hats the academic community the
hobbyist the enthusiast diary are
interesting this are saying well I can
do a lot more things than just games I
mean I'm going to give you just a
glimpse of what some of these are
academics and enthusiasts are working on
it could be that some of them are people
in this audience I believe I've talked
to a few of you that have been using
Kinect for your experiments and this is
an example of how you can use this for
video capture so if you want to get a
physical model of say a room you could
better connect device and move it around
and it's going to get a map much faster
than you can draw and that's kind of
like the idea behind it which is of
course very different than gaming so i
got my connect here's the box and i
decided after all the cool stuff that
others have been doing with it and the
fact
now its waters hecht that people have
figured out how to move the solos and
they have figured out how to get the
colors and the depth images out of it I
decided I would try to use the depth of
the color image and put them together
and then project the image back out into
space in order to recreate the original
three-dimensional objects that were
captured by the cameras in the original
position orientation and size so if
you're looking at here right now is not
just a video on but it's actually the 3d
reconstruction and right now i'm showing
it from the point of view of the camera
and if i zoom out a little bit and move
it around i can move the image around in
three dimensions and you can see that
the objects in myself and t kappa right
here that they are actually
reconstructed in three-dimensional space
so we have a really true almost
holographic camera image of course you
see that since the camera only looks on
one point of view that's a big shadow
behind me right here and if you look at
me from the other side there's no back
to my head because the camera can't see
that but apart from that that's what my
room looks like yeah so the idea is that
if I based on the fact that we have a
breath camera we can reduce the east of
and can use it for kinds of purposes all
right and there's more to come so i'm
going to try next to see if i can use
these 3d views and put them into another
3d environment in order to mix realistic
people captured receives a connect with
a computer-generated imagery but i'm not
quite honest it yet so this is one of
the first hacks that was posted about a
week or two weeks after connect started
shipping so that's why I included it
there are people trying to do all kinds
of different things that probably we
have never imagined in this one
you can use this for making music video
Oh
you
you get the idea there are all kinds of
applications including some for helping
the visual impaired or even some
disabled people so this is an
interesting example to and I was talking
to a couple of professors that are
looking to prospectively you skin F for
the elderly maybe like put it in our
room to monitor did they get up that day
they do their routine chores they take
their medicines so there are all kinds
of ideas that were just didn't even
imagine
you
turn right
walk forward until the next information
appears
keep left
attention obstacles I'm left side
you
even if you are not visually impaired
you come put on your key net helmet
you'll be starting the next party think
about it there are tons of applications
that people are working on I mean here
there is like that just a bunch i'm not
going to go over them on nash your
natural user interaction how can you use
this to interact with competing other
devices differently virtual and
augmented reality i'm just going to
flash through this just to mention that
there are tons of them this visual art
audio and music human activity analysis
other applications there are tons of
them so given the interest that we've
seen in the academic community will Emma
sorry started working with our partners
in Xbox to see if we can release SDK for
windows and you may say well what's the
difference between the SDK and what the
kin that hackers are trying to do what
they only have access to the depth data
and here we in addition to the depth
data provide audio the microphone array
as I will describe later direct control
of the kinect sensor the system API as
well as the higher-level libraries that
allow you to do beamforming with a
microphone speech recognition and
scalable tracking upon us as well as
other functionality so we hope that if
we provide this in addition to the depth
data it's going to enable even more
opportunities so maybe next year when we
come to the latter salmon in something
like hundred there's like over thousands
of such applications so we're working on
this arm at connect SDK and tomorrow I
will have a demo if you gonna if you
want to stop by the demo fest to show a
few of the capabilities of the current
version as it is now of the kinect sdk
for audio and speech recognition so now
that you've seen what are the you know
gaming applications and the non gaming
applications of kinect i'm going to go
in more detail and describe how it works
what is the software underneath then
let's start with audio processing
so one of the things that we like to do
is not only get rid of the controller
for video games but also get rid of the
controller for watching TV maybe like if
you are like me you have a number of
remote controls in your living room and
whenever you want to use yours as a
where is it who has it looking under the
couch look under the you can't find it
wouldn't it be nice if you could just do
something like this can't really hear
let me try again
it's same force
in this in this example you can post a
video you can start at the double line
and do things like this and this is
already shipping so the idea is can you
use your voice for some things you want
to use gestures for other things you
like to use your voice so what is the
role of speech recognition in connect
it's actually we think quite
complementary to gesture like there is a
game called kinectimals where you're
actually talking to your animal and if
you're playing with an animal you can
pet the animal but you can also talk say
jump come here things like this let you
do with our real pet when you have when
you want to do voice control without
having to pull buttons on the screen I
mean you can today we just your select
something with your hand but if you
don't but if you do that then you take
real state of the screen that you cannot
do for other other things so if you just
use speech then you can use most of the
screen for say the content of your movie
for example or if you want to access
long lists we're scrolling you know may
take a long time so those are like
places where you may want to use speech
unfortunately if you have been exposed
to speech recognition it's often hard to
get it to work properly and that's when
you have a closer kin microphone you
have like a phone or something next and
close to your mouth imagine the
challenge when the guys from xbox came
to us and said well we want to do that
but you know we want to put the
microphone in the device next to the TV
where you are like 10 feet like three
meters four meters away in for those of
you that are familiar with all your
processing you know that it captures a
ton of noise and it's just gonna be hell
so of course we told them you must be
crazy right and they said no no no but
we still want you two to try so there
was a person in in my team event a chef
that took up on the challenge and
started working on it and in fact he's
the one that is having the most fun
normally have to sometimes push the guys
in my team come on work but this guy
comes to work so well I don't work I
just play Prince to the lab and starts
tinkering with all these gadgets he had
a great time so let me tell you how the
architecture for the audio stack in
kinetics so there's distributed into two
parts
you have processing the happens in the
Kinect device and processing that
happens in the console the processing
that happens in the Kinect device is
that it has four microphones and this in
this case I put two loudspeakers but if
you have a surround system you may have
a 5.1 or 7.1 surround system then if the
system is playing back let's say a movie
what you want to be able to cancel that
sound or that music out so that when you
say Xbox pause the system will listen to
you otherwise it will hear itself so to
do that what we need to this acoustic
echo cancellation but because its
multi-channel we have to multi-channel
acoustic cancellation which is a big
challenges we will see later and then a
microphone array so that we can being on
a former beam in point to the right
person and not point to to the person
that is in the vacuum cleaner clean the
room or the dishwasher or the dog
barking or the kids running around so
that we can just eliminate the noise by
focusing on the person that we're
interested once this is done then it
goes to an acoustic echo suppressor to
reduce the remaining echo the husband
castle and uh noise suppressor that
attenuates the noise our person in the
background and that goes to both the
speech recognition which can be using
the voice interface examples that I just
show you or you could do source
separation speaker identification who's
the person talking or you could use it
for a voice child so now I'm going to
describe of all these components is I
don't have time to go into very much
depth i will just talk about these two
the multi-channel i could acoustic echo
canceller and the microphone array so
the first of all let me tell you about
the geometry this is the geometry of the
microphones they are not the four
microphones are not equally spaced and
that's because we could only afford to
have four and the nonlinear separation
means that we can better balance the
coverage of the frequency band
this is also a diagram that shows that
part of the directionality pattern what
we want in this case is the microphones
to point forward not backward and that
wasn't true at the beginning where it
was capturing a lot of the fan noise in
the device or like the TV noise so this
is important in to do that it's a little
bit of an art so you need to play not
just with the microphone capsule itself
but you also need to play with the
rubber and the boot around it and the
plastic and enclosure because all of
that form part of the directionality
pattern then to do the acoustic echo
cancellation let me describe first what
the mono acoustic echo cancellation is
this a technique that has been around
for 30 years or so and in fact you be
using it when you use the speakerphone
for a number of years although it's only
until the last a decade that the speaker
phones were good before they were
cutting you off there were half duplex
but what they do is essentially the
speaker produces a sound that goes into
the microphone through a filter which is
authorized by the response of the room
the reflections in the walls and the
size of the room the number of people
there whether you have carpet or hard
surfaces things like this so what we
like to do is estimate that detail
filter that is essentially almost the
same ideally the same so that we can
simulate the result subtract a component
in all we have left is what the person
is saying if we've done a perfect job
and this is the equations if you done a
perfect job we will cancel one hundred
percent of the echo of course as you
know in practice there are many reasons
why will not be able to do a perfect job
then when you have let's say two
speakers then you may say let's do the
same thing let's put two filters instead
then it turns out that if you do the
math a stereo acoustic echo cancellation
r has a non-uniqueness problem there are
infinite solutions to this problem and
that was something that the researchers
in bed laughs that did early work on
acoustic of cancellation discover so
then we went back to our Xbox Francis
and you know we can do
think harder please so Yvonne went back
to the lab and came up with a solution
but what he did it saying well i'm going
to have one feature that i'm going to
estimate just one in 26 features one per
channel and the idea behind that is we
decompose both saying the two speakers
are the room is the same it's just that
the speakers are located in a different
location so there is a part or the field
of the transfer function that is going
to be common then there is a part that
is going to be variable so let's
differentiate it the to fix filters are
obtained through a calibration process
so when you install it and you push on
the audio calibration there is an audio
sound that is being played through all
the different speakers and that helps
calibrate the the filters and this is
what it sounds like anyway they
initially even when they're with a chirp
signal which sounds like boom and it
sounds so loud that everyone was
covering their ear say well you're not
planning to use that are you so he tried
like 500 different pieces of audio music
and this piece of music that you listen
to happens to have every single
frequency in the audible frequency range
that's not what users would perceive but
that's one of the main reasons why we
picked it because we needed to scan the
whole frequency range it's something
that kind of sounds cool so this
multi-channel acoustical cancellation
because of the nonlinearities the fact
that the system has a finite response
and in reality this lasts for a long
time because of noises and all other
things he manages to attenuate 15 to 20
DB echo which together with the noise
suppressor and the acoustical echo
suppressor gets up to 35 decibels of
echo suppression which we thought was
sufficient to
to make this useful in addition we have
another component which is the
microphone array processing and when you
can see here this is the angle in the
x-axis and the frequency in the y-axis
red dark red means louder yellow is
middle and blue is quiet so what this
tells you is that at the round I don't
know 20 degree is what there is your
target source then you want to eliminate
something here that's another way of
viewing this which is maybe at minus 5
so the system can put put unknown as
it's called to attenuate so what I'm
going to listen to this direction I'm
going to 10 you ate that direction then
it doesn't dynamically so this wise this
is why it's called an adaptive
beamformer and it can pick anywhere that
you want to come focus to a particular
person or you can just pick the one that
is the loudest or you know we can also
reduce on average at least 3 or 6 DB of
noise and if the strong sources
directionally continue it even more than
that plus if you do spatial filtering
which is a nonlinear process in a lot of
the beam former Tsar linear processing
if you do some nonlinear processing you
can get even more another six or 12 DB
so once we did that you can come in all
these components that I show you up at
first and then you get what you know
mathematically we think that must be an
optimal solution unfortunately it's not
because each component was derived
independently and it has a number of
parameters that it was used to to this
vidas i'm so what we did here what even
did is let's look at a great grid search
with our favorite approximation to for
computational efficiency to explore all
possible combinations of all these
parameters so that I look at end-to-end
how well my audio pipeline works and one
possible way of doing this is like
bringing a bunch of people and say hope
listen to this this is some good doesn't
that that's not very practical so we use
a program called task which is a
computer program that has been
standardized that is going to
approximate what people would say about
the quality of the speech signal so we
run this in a
cluster and then we also look at the
results on a speech recognizer and
that's how this was are evaluated and
just let me show you roughly were what
were the recognition error rates here in
the y axis as a function or the volume
of the loudspeaker as we said because
the echo was not perfectly cancel if you
do nothing you see the black line which
means it's not usable I mean at that
kind of error rate this is definitely
something that we could not use if we
pull all the components that I described
before you can get the red line which
means that now for relatively quiet
volume it seems quite use usable but
still if the volume is a little bit
louder the error rate was still too high
after these things were optimized as I
mentioned with all the parameters
properly optimized you see the white
line which is a lower error rate and
then if you retrain the speech
recognizer so that it doesn't get
trained with clean speech but rather
with pseudo clean after going through
this process you get a further
improvement then we thought that this
was a good enough to build a lot of
speech applications and that's how we we
develop this tomorrow you can see a game
of an example of a popular game at least
in the u.s. called wheel of fortune
where you see letters like this and you
need to guess what the catchphrase is in
this case we also had to add another
component which is a Doran's
verification for example you might say
this right sentence which raise your
hand is a happy-go-lucky guy that is in
this case the correct sentence but you
might say the user may say a happy go
lucky man and they sound almost the same
in fact they are the same except for the
last word that if you do scores
CLE you might see that both of them are
similar in fact if you have a non-native
speaker say the correct one a
happy-go-lucky guy they may get a lower
score overall than unknown that a native
speaker sent a happy-go-lucky month man
the man part may score worse but the
resume score better so we have to
develop our word dependent address
verification
so you can come tomorrow to the booth
and may be able to play with this is
pretty pretty fun and you'll see how the
this is Ben not on the Xbox but actually
on a PC using the the current version
that we have on of the connect SDK so
now that I've talked about audio
processing I'm going to go into the
other part of the talk that uses the
depth information and first of all I'm
going to describe what a depth sensor
isn't how it works briefly and then
describe a few applications once you
develop on once you use that information
so motion capture motion capture has
been used in Hollywood movies for a good
number of years and many of you probably
have seen the movie Avatar well avatar
was probably film with something like
this you the actors and actresses where
these special suits and they have this
kind of ping-pong balls attached to them
so with that they can capture all the
movements inve up your hybrid frame rate
that is expensive and you know how
expensive it is to make one of these
Hollywood productions right so there are
other mechanisms there but this is what
was the state of the art for motion
capture and what we wanted to do is come
with use another technique that is much
simpler and cheaper to do something
similar and for this is what connect is
using this def camera or 3d camera and
it's using the concept of structure IR
light infrared keep fast accurate and
let me show you roughly the principle
behind it imagine that you have a
projector the IR projector that emits a
pattern in this case let's assume just
for example that is just this good set
of lines then you have a camera an
infrared camera that is seen the
reflection on an object so if the
trajectories here and you put an object
here is the it's going to get the lines
making the camera bigger just like when
you take a picture if you move the
object further away it's going to be a
smaller and smaller
so the fact that these lines are further
apart or o closer together will tell you
how far apart the object is then thus
they send the essential concept that is
used to determine the death not only
that if you have an object that is not
just a plane that has some contour like
that one you're going to see an image
that is not just that it has like some
curvature so the way this is actually
done is not with stripes but rather is
what it's called a random pattern it
looks random that is not random is
pseudo random the system knows what
pattern is a meeting it projects on and
then it captures that image and it's
trying to do correlation to see what I
know all the possible ways that this
pattern will be distorted depending on
how far away my object could be and it's
going to look at all possible deaths for
each pixel to maximize the correlation
so in this is no correlation algorithm
and based on that you can in this case
you can / impose it and you can see the
depth which means that this island this
system will provide for each pixel of
the def camera up death it's an is here
is here and this is what you look like
you see the hand when it's darker is
because it's closer so this is the
output of this algorithm after doing the
correlation
so as you can imagine using this kind of
image after you've done the day I our
random pattern and the correlation to
find out the actual depth can be much
more useful than using the regular
cameras for things like pose estimation
the regular comer RGB only works well
when there is enough light where is this
depth camera because it uses infrared it
can work in the dark which in fact a lot
of people that use this in movie
theaters is like darkened rooms
otherwise who not be able to work also
they are much more robust using def
camera to clatter to add effects to
color to is just looking at the depth so
there is nothing like using that
compared to that's kind of like a honey
example so now that you have an idea of
how the depth sensor works this is the
basic information that all the first
skinit hacks were trying to use they get
this image that is a great image black
or darker if it is closer and grey or
white if he's further away and that's
that what the device provides but then
we've provided a bunch of additional
technology on top of that that allows us
to do things like skeletal tracking head
pose facial expression so let me tell
you roughly how this works the idea
behind pose estimation is let's say you
have our person and what you want to do
is find out where the bones would be
like if you have that idea then you can
figure out when the guys kicking the
ball or like hitting the pimp on our
ball or things like this so the goal is
to estimate the scale low and find out
all the coordinates and all the angles
and things like this and in fact connect
tracks 20 body joints in real time so
this is information that will be
provided in the Kinect sdk for Windows
that is not currently using any of these
hundreds of projects today but it is
hard I mean there are many cases where
you can imagine if I have a dead camera
captured on ok so this this is an
extreme case obviously but just to say
well is that a leg or is that the the
rope what is up there people of
different sizes and makes it hard I mean
this has to work with children it has to
work with big people and the first
version didn't work with women that were
wearing skirts it was confused by that
so it has to work in all kinds of
conditions very very tough there are
dogs there are babies running around all
kinds of things going on so to make this
work in practice even if use that camera
which is a much more robust mechanism
it's still very tough so this is where
the our colleagues in MSR Cambridge
Jamie Sean and his other colleagues did
a lot of the work on the skeletal
tracking park essentially this is a high
level how the algorithm works this is
the role def image you see the face is a
little bit darker is moving forward then
it's the next step is trying to infer
the body parts so there is a definition
of a number of different body parts with
different colors and if you have that
then you can hypothesize where the
joints are where my elbow is my wrist is
my shoulder and all my other
articulations and then you can come up
with a mechanism like this in 3d which
is what you can use for a lot of these
other games and other applications as
well so this is an example of how you
can get from the depth image to the
infirmary parts and you see the
different colors in real time lots of
computations per second
even though it's secluded slow works so
how does this work so it's essentially
machine learning algorithm using
computer vision in this case using the
depth camera so what how it works is let
you have the big image there and for
each pixel you take a window which is
you look at the pixels around that pixel
like this and then you build a
classifier that says further window what
is the probability that that is body
part a or let's say the hand or the
lower arm or the elbow or all these
other parts then you find this
conditional probability then we use our
discriminative approach then we learn
the classifier from training data we
collected a lot of training data through
into the system and build this
classifier in this particular
implementation we build a decision tree
classifier which essentially it's asking
questions compute some function and it
says is this bigger than this treasure
or smaller and if in CS it looks at the
distribution of all the body parts how
many times it's the elbow how many times
is the head you know these kind of
things if not then you keep asking these
questions until you I mean you build the
death of the tree and that's how you
build is classified it's more
complicated than this but this is just
to give you an idea of how it works so
for example in this case this is the
input death there's a harder case or the
person is leaning forward then this is
the correct ground truth so initially
it's been annotated by a human and this
is what the system wouldn't learn after
a while this is if it has back to so you
can only learn if the tree has only
depth to can only learn two different
body parts that 3e color are for body
parts the phone
how 67 it's getting better
so you can you can get an idea of how
the system is this working and it's
easier let's say in that case that in
this case what you see here is just each
point is completely independently of the
other points of course it does not make
sense that you do that so that the next
stage is to say well points around me
are likely similar until there is a
discontinuity and that additional
constraint can be used to smooth these
discontinuities this is how you can use
more than one tree so rather than using
a single tree you can use many trees in
that house so if you use one tree two
trees three trees it gets a cleaner and
you can see the accuracy improves us to
use more trees and once you get to four
or five it starts to saturate so then
the next step is once you have the body
part classifier you want to infer the
joints where they are I'm not going to
talk about this but there is another
machine learning algorithm that you can
use to try to infer that and one of the
things that the guys in cambridge are
working on now is can we do that in one
step be like a big model and not have to
go through the body parts and that may
have some advantages under the model is
more complex so this is another example
of how the system works in 3d and you
consider joints as well in the image
so the final part of the talk I'll be
talking about some other work that some
of my colleagues in my team have been
working on together with other
colleagues in MSR asian which is
determining the head post and facial
expression you could view this as an
extension of the skeletal tracking
except that skeletal tracking is not
using the head at all it says using like
a big block for the head that wouldn't
it be nice if we're coming all all the
times our expression is concentrated on
the face our eyebrows smile found in all
kinds of expressions so this work is
targeted towards can we understand more
of the gestures with in the face where
is the person looking at all kinds of
things so first of all let me show you a
video of a new application that will be
shipping in the spring release of the
Xbox which is called avatar connect an
avatar connect is interesting in that is
way if I think it's very fun in that
what it does is the system captures my
movements transmits my skeletal tracking
through the internet to another person
that is thousands of miles away perhaps
and then it animates an avatar so if I
do this my avatar will do this and then
if I do this my avatar will turn around
so let me show you what the
possibilities of this are very big big
game bring it on all right guys five
minutes to kick up let's hear your
predictions go tigers by two touchdowns
hey guys the jacks are gonna run all
over you in your dreams the Ducks are
going down
hey guys welcome back
hey me honey so I love tonight's episode
what did you that's it five stars kind
of rock ditto she's the only reason i
watch the show too much drama two stars
Facebook bad what do you think
others work so in this case we use a
different technique we build what we
call a linear deform deformable model
which is a mesh as you can see of
triangles that is especially especially
designed for tracking the different
mouth positions nose eyes and eyebrows
and so and so forth and we have a
mathematical model that says that it has
this expression which essentially has
two terms one term that says what is the
rotation and orientation of your face
compared to the canonical so you have a
canonical face and you can do this this
may be the distance and the other one is
are you doing things with in your face
given a particular person gays are you
frowning are you smiling so these are
the two coefficients so the way this is
the model and with this model given
sufficient parameters we can make this
mesh a mimic other of one and the users
too so what we need to do is at runtime
trying to estimate those parameters
because those are the parameters that
we're going to transmit to the other end
and animate the avatar and to do this
what we need to is matching what we see
we look at the map will complete a mesh
for the face we need to face tracking oh
I'll have that later we need to face
detection face tracking post detection
and then trying to estimate all these
parameters of that model that maximize
the likelihood we have our Pro lipstick
our mechanism and do until convergence
until both this curve represents the
texture map or the for a particular
image and this is what the model tells
you we find the closest match so to
initialize it what we do is we take a
large number of faces when we compute a
single one by normalizing the Desai's
the orientation and then normalizing a
bunch of other you know aspects we can
like for a single frame we know we
average several frames we get a smoother
image we this is princess the texture
model where we've changed the
orientation so the input with your face
detection we do face alignment we
compute these other points and then
initialize the model and then trying to
track it as you move in and that's a lot
of how the basics of how this technique
works is been done by zijun news and you
John and qin kai and a bunch of the
people in an incubation team in xbox so
in summary I think we've been very
surprised that quenette has
revolutionized gaming market place's
been very successful but not just gaming
we've seen people trying to use this
technology for a lot of applications and
that reminds me of when the pc was
started in the early 80s people for no
one is going to use this thing is only
good for like a spreadsheet and it turns
out that you could do anything on a pc
so this is kind of like a new platform
for building programs it's just very
different platform than before and what
we've seen with all the enthusiasts in
the hobbyists and the academics is that
we're just scratching the surface of
what's possible voice and gestures are
natural for users and we want to
leverage it we don't we want to allow
our users to use a different type of
morality natural user interfaces but at
the same time is what is natural for you
sir to make it really natural for user
is very hard to get right there is a lot
of heart audio speech and computer
vision technology in here and we know
that it we can make it toward to some
extent but it's a lot more work that
needs to be done to make it really
robust so this is the beginning of an
era is not definitely not the DN by any
chance so this is version 1 we are
already hard work on the next versions
and as I said my the guys in my team are
so excited to work on this but we need
any help that we can get and I hope that
a number of you or your students are
interested in helping us in any possible
dimension improve the technology thank
you very much
Oh
you